.
Hier, iss mal.
Unsere Grafikerin Melanie
hat sich gefragt,
warum wir bei heißem Wetter
eigentlich weniger Hunger haben.
Heute beantworten wir also mal
eine interne Frage.
Zunächst gibt es beim Essen
einen "thermischen Effekt"
oder, wie man im Englischen sagt,
"Thermic Effect of Food"
kurz: TEF.
Dieser Effekt erklärt sich
folgendermaßen:
wenn wir etwas essen,
muss unser Körper
das Gegessene verstoffwechseln, d.h.,
in andere Produkte umwandeln,
mit denen unser Körper
etwas anfangen kann.
Zum Stoffwechsel gehört
auch die Fettverbrennung,
die ich in diesem Video
schon mal erklärt habe.
D.h., einerseits erhalten wir
durchs Essen natürlich Energie,
andererseits verbraucht unser Körper
beim Essen und verdauen Energie.
Der Energieverbrauch erhöht sich
gegenüber dem Grundverbrauch,
wenn wir nichts essen.
Dabei entsteht u.a. auch Wärme.
Bei Proteinen ist der thermische
Effekt übrigens besonders hoch.
Bei Kohlenhydraten und Fetten
ist der etwas geringer.
Bei Ratten hat man beobachtet,
dass sie bei 35 °C
gerade mal 10% von dem aßen, was sie
bei 24 °C zu sich nehmen würden.
Möglicherweise, um den Körper
nicht durch Essen weiter aufzuwärmen.
In der Folge beobachtete man
einen starken Gewichtsverlust
bei höheren Temperaturen.
Mit Menschen gibt es keine
vergleichbar konkreten Studien,
aber ich kenne das auch, dass
ich im Sommer weniger Hunger habe.
Oder wie geht es euch?
Aber neben dem thermischen Effekt von
Essen gibt es noch andere Gründe,
warum Essen im Sommer
weniger attraktiv ist.
Erst dieses Jahr kam eine
psychologische Studie heraus,
die besagt, dass wir bei Hitze
weniger hilfsbereit sind.
Das mag schlicht und einfach
daran liegen,
dass uns Hitze stresst.
Und Stress kann nicht nur
Appetit dämpfen,
sondern ebenfalls
die Körpertemperatur erhöhen.
Außerdem greifen wir im Sommer
natürlich bevorzugt zu kaltem Essen.
Lieber mal einen Salat,
statt eine dampfend heiße Suppe.
Und jeder weiß,
dass Salat nicht schmeckt.
Nein, mal im Ernst, manche
Wissenschaftler sind der Meinung,
dass warmes Essen
prinzipiell schmackhafter ist,
weil bei höheren Temperaturen
die Geschmacks-und Aromastoffe
besser rauskommen.
D.h., vielleicht haben wir im Sommer
einfach weniger Appetit,
weil kaltes Essen
nicht so gut schmeckt
und warmes Essen zu heiß ist.
Schönschlau.
Wie ist es bei euch, habt ihr
im Sommer auch weniger Hunger?
Und was ist euer
Sommer-Lieblingsessen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare
zusammen mit euren Fragen.
Bis nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin.
Bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)